tu pars quatre ans dans un vaisseau
spatial
quatre ans on apesanteur c'est infernal
alors tu peux partir avec Jean et
dernier
qu'est-ce que tu reproches le plus au
bon Dieu
les chauves les impuissons les
homosexuels les homosexuels
tu préfères incarner en Marguerite Duras
ou Marilyn
monroection
alors imagine maintenant qu'on te greffe
un cerveau j'espère qu'il sera sympa il
y a trois solutions il y a trois
cerveaux comme ça qui sont dans la
petite boîte tu as le choix les Dick
Rivers Eddy Mitchell ou Johnny Hallyday
et Eddy Mitchell j'irai pas forcément
pas Dick Rivers
je prendrais le cerveau d'Eddy Mitchell
avec
Johnny Hallyday tu prends le serveur
Eddy Mitchell d'accord non mais
[Rires]
[Musique]
est-ce que ce qui fait le plus honte
c'est qu'il trouve le lit avec une fille
avec deux mecs
avec une fille moi
une fille ah bon
une fille j'ai rien
puis j'aurais peur surtout qu'il essaie
de venir avec nous deux quoi
c'est peut-être même plus une question
de honte alors le mot d'amour que tu
trouves le plus con tu en as beaucoup
c'est merci un mec qui dit merci après
l'amour ça c'est fréquent un mec il dit
encore ou un mec qui dit toujours oui
oui oui oui
je déteste les gens qui sont toujours
d'accord on finit par un pari arriver
alors tu l'as trompé et il te dit qu'il
va te punir est-ce que tu préfères et
qui te pince
qui te morde pour qu'il te piquent
quoi
tu pars 4 ans dans un vaisseau spatial
quatre ans on apesanteur c'est infernal
alors tu peux partir avec Jean et
dernier
ou Catherine Lara elle est dans tous les
voyages
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu